foreign
they came in there tens of thousands
masses of people on both sides lining
Windsor's long walk
I've got very sad really you know my
eyes welled up because I thought that's
the last time I'm seeing her she's an
amazing woman and she you know she she
was so beautiful and so dignified and so
dedicated and it's just yeah it was
amazing to have been here
been here you know to to actually
witness this it was it was very
important to me
and it was always going to be an
emotional farewell
the crowds knew this as they followed
the processions every step
some visibly overcome
others more contemplative
major renichima brought his young family
to help them to understand the meaning
of Duty I think you know um you know the
people here a celebration of her life
a celebration of everything she stood
for as well
thoughts that were shared by Emma who
came here before Dawn to be close to her
Queen I think everyone is just really
grateful and thankful that they can be
here for her final Journey back to
Winter
a journey that was witnessed across
Generations as the crowds begin to make
their way home they'll have a chance to
pause and reflect on what they've seen
and experienced here today
there are a few places that will fill
the Queen's death as much as Windsor
this Berkshire Town held a very special
place in her heart
and that love was reciprocated by the
people here today
in remembrance of an extraordinary life
of service
Ashish Joshi Sky News in Windsor